welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and it's time to battle
rock and roll as we are now at the
finale for rings of power season 1. the
Lord of the Rings show answers a lot of
questions in its last episode and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down what happens what it means
for the future and also giving our
review on the series as a whole bold
spoilers from here on out so if you
don't want anything ruined then I'll
recommend that you head out now please
hit the Thumbs Up Button if you think
the video is precious and make sure you
subscribe but breakdowns that you'll be
Galadriel you stuck around for even the
puns are anyway without the way huge
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into rings of Power episode 8.
foreign
[Music]
last week saw the aftermath of the birth
of Mount Doom which completely ravaged
the Southlands normally I'd say One does
not simply change the text of the
Southlands in tomorrow but after Adar
took over the realm it became his Muriel
decided to return to numenor in order to
gather more forces and both Galadriel
and Hal bran traveled out together the
Harford set out looking for this
Stranger in order to warn him he was
being tracked by feminine and the people
who played Stan and Kim in the music
videos lastly was jiren who told elrond
and his son to leave the digging and he
accidentally awakened the balrog whilst
refusing to help the elves and that
should be a fully caught up and this
entry picks up with the stranger we get
a strong focus on his eye similar to how
last week started with gladriel here he
is in Allen Galen which is known as the
Greenwood and once the shadow dog spread
this became known as mirkwood he finds
the Apple at Nori gave him last week but
he drops is only for it to be picked up
by what seems to be her however
now we see the dweller is here they say
they're there to save Sauron but we'll
we'll get into it now over at Reagan
Galadriel arrives with Hal bran for the
elves to heal him he ends up wandering
through Keller brimbo's workshop and I
was sitting there like you [ __ ]
they discussed the essence of valinor
being trapped by thano he's described as
having a distinct personality flaw and
that he possessed too much pride and
though he was highly skilled this need
to be modeled led to the creation of
several things at spell Doom for his
people as for the Rings a lot of them
were made by the grandson of thano with
Keller brimbor handling the greatest of
the three in total 19 were created with
16 being the ones that Sauron also had a
hand in these were given as gifts with
Saron planning to use them as a way to
bring those that wore them under his
sway Sauron crafted the One Ring himself
and when he put it on the elves
instantly became aware of what was going
on they hid most of them and passed
someone to the dwarves those Sauron
gained 15 back and he then passed them
out he gave nine to the men knowing that
they would be the easiest to manipulate
and the wearers ended up becoming the
ring rates he gave six to the dwarves
who became very wealthy but they weren't
swayed by Sauron due to their tough
Spirits they did however become greedier
because of them which eventually led to
their downfall anyway a they of course
brought with them the extended life
which wasn't originally planned by
Sauron as he wanted to give them Sully
to the elves who were already Immortal
now it is important to bear in mind that
an additional ring was given a Kaza Doom
so in total the dwarves had seven
remaining three stayed with the elves
and we get a strong focus on them when
the episode comes to fruition they
weren't created in order for the elves
to conquer and instead they were used to
Healing understanding and also creation
the episode is called Allied tying in
with how allies are used to create them
and without sauron's input they never
would have been made halbrand calls this
knowledge a gift and this is the first
major clue that he's in fact the big bad
Keller brimble initially pitches the
idea of a crown made for gilgalad but of
course they end up making the Rings
which also holds the jewels once more
there's mention of the Unseen World
which we know from the first episode
that Sauron was experimenting with
gilgalad is the only one who sees how
dangerous it could be and he instructs
that they all go back to Linden Keller
brimbor has clearly been manipulated by
halbrand and Galadriel starts to suspect
something as off as the episode goes on
now the reveal that Hal bran is Sauron
is something we've talked about a lot in
theater time
and whilst we've often said that we
don't think it's the case this is mainly
because of how obvious it was to the
point that I honestly thought it was red
herring my money was on disa with her
turning into Sauron and then saying suck
a decent nuts but you can't win them all
and looking back there were several
Clues laced throughout the series that
gave away the halbrand twist when he
first met Galadriel he warned her about
how appearances could be deceptive upon
being taken to numenor he was extremely
interested in the Forge and he
constantly pushed his way into trying to
be a Smith it was also the whispering
and pharison's ears Sauron and the book
is someone who manipulated the character
and this was referred to as whispering
to a subtext now he's often hinted at
his dark past and he clearly had crossed
paths with a dog before now it all
stated that he had killed Sauron and
though halbrand recognized him a door
didn't recognize Hal brand he refused to
answer who he was when he was asked to
leave the barn and there was a lot of
ambiguity about the character's past and
this also kindly ties back to gilgalad
who warned in episode 1 that if
Galadriel stuck around then Darkness
would return to the land she of course
held Hal bran sailed back to the point
he was discovered by the men of numenor
and as I've been saying for ages it's
all connected I'm in the source material
Sauron shape-shifted into the form of
anatar who was known as the Lord of
gifts he appeared Angelic and went to
Keller brimborne as Alvin Smith offering
them the knowledge and material to bring
about the creation of the Rings Hal
brand is a different form to this with
him seemingly being a cast out king of
the Southlands similar how Aragorn would
be down the line none of his
southlanders knew who he was and they
simply took his word for it once more
showing how he manipulated his way in
Glad real is all like you dirty rat you
killed my brother and though kalaborn
was thought to be slain too we do know
that he's still alive due to him popping
up later in the timeline Sauron is said
to have come from the shadows and I
think they deliberately did the
celestial event with a stranger in his
eye to misdirect us in a thinking he was
the character however for the series he
rose once more from the sea and got
revenge on the one who wronged him in a
door let me know what you think of the
Hal brand twist below and where you
think they're gonna go with the
character in the future obviously the
people of the Southland still think that
he's their King so I can't see him using
them as a way to combat a dog's forces
kinda bad by Galadriel did not at least
send a warning to them that halbrand is
the dark lord uh yeah and they're likely
gonna fall under his Rule and probably
be corrupted by him cut back to numenor
and we see Aryan being tasked by
farazone to capture the likeness of the
king before he passes away after being
the second dying King this week that
mistook a woman at his bedside for
someone else she travels out to the
palantir the king warns her about the
fall of numenor which is likely an event
the second season will focus around this
was more about the little pieces that
came together for the creation of the
Rings so I can see season 2 having that
as a pivotal point we never learn what
happens with the plantier and also a
seal door is a plot Point that's dropped
however his horse went off the leash
last week nikenzia being a similar
situation to what happened with Aragorn
in The Two Towers Barrack ended up
finding him I'm guessing that the same
thing is gonna happen with your boy on
top of this we never have resolution to
the balrog thing either and it all kind
of felt like a missed opportunity for a
season finale Ali either way alron drops
the line hope is never mere
not even when it is Mika which is
something that Gail galad said in
episode one the clip keeps getting
flagged and the video keeps getting
blocked so here it is over a still image
hoop
is never near elrond
[Music]
even when it is Mika now from here we
cut the saw non-blondes
oh that's that's the worst one ever and
they explained the hermit had Star
constellation this can only be spotted
in roon and they start to basically make
him feel like I do when people start to
gas me up that I'm better at breakdowns
in duggies no one is though mate not
getting gassed on this honestly I felt
it was a mistake doing the gifts line
from hellbrand earlier as it kinda
ruined any tension due to it now being
clearly him that was Sauron and not the
stranger they kind of played their hand
on this by giving us the reveal earlier
and it was a similar thing with the
Mortal change but the audience was ahead
of the show and waiting for it to catch
up to them now we see that the half foot
have snuck in using Gilly suits from
Call of Duty and they go to rescue him
however
but the stranger ends up saving his
friends after a battle with the three I
really like the way this was presented
and the effect work on it with the
stones and environment floating around
that worked really well in my opinion
elements of It kind of ripped on the
breakdance fight from the fellowship
with the Halfords showing their strength
of character and taking a stand against
former powerful beings throughout these
breakdowns we've talked about how the
stranger needed a staff to harness his
powers and this is presented to him in
the form of nori giving him the Dwellers
had me imagining a what if world where
the stranger gets to become Sauron and
he ends up delivering a speech riffing
on the wall and that he dropped to the
balrog he mentions setting them back to
the shadows and also reveals another
form of them in which they appear like
white figures this is similar to how the
ring wraiths did when Frodo put on the
ring they realize he's not the stranger
and call him an Easter though we don't
get it confirmed it is heavily hinted at
that the stranger is Gandalf for a
number of reasons they play slightly
loose with it and have him dropping a
line similar to what Gandalf did in The
Fellowship of the Rings when in doubt
Eleanor brandyford
always follow your nose this is a play
on
always follow your nose
this changes things from the book as
originally the blue Wizards came to
Middle Earth first and then Gandalf
didn't arrive until much later in the
timeline it also came from the sea where
as he drops down through a meteor I've
been re-watching the Peter Jackson
Trilogy in preparation for this show and
there are several lines that give us
hints towards the stranger being Gandalf
bursley was his love for the halflings
which the show is now telling us
developed due to his relationship with
the half foot there's also one of his
many nicknames when Gandalf is
resurrected as the white wizard he
recounts some of the things that he was
called in the past and tells Aragorn
that he was named the gray Pilgrim The
Stranger of course wears all gray and
even the beard in hair he carries are
similar to Gandalf the estari were
ageless but they all appeared as elderly
men so that they come across an assuming
and frail to those that face them this
wasn't the case and just like things
were with Sauron appearances could be
deceptive is is a pretty obvious twist
so no prizes for getting it right and it
was made even more obvious by the fact
Amazon kept the character's name a
secret had it just been a normal wizard
I guess they would have let us know in
advance but still The Stranger is one of
the stronger characters in the series
I'm glad to see them including Gandalf
with him
[Music]
sadly dies which is sad Arc and the long
and Winding Road ends for our traveler
here rise the half foots used to abandon
people to die here they sit with sadak
as he passes away it's a shame he didn't
give that opportunity to other people
your monster now we could have crossed
to the numenorians and see Muriel trying
to practice her Paces got lots of Vibes
of the scene in The Great Escape in
which they try and pretend Donald
Pleasence isn't blind nalindile mentions
why he held out Galadriel earlier in the
season we learned his name awesome and L
friend and the pair make a pact together
now though it doesn't happen in this
finale sadly we know what happens with
Muriel in the kingdom and a disability
will clearly allow people to manipulate
air they returned to find black flags
strung up on everything announcing that
the King has sadly passed away elsewhere
at a region we see that they're now
experimenting with the Unseen World and
how brand once more provides clear
guidance on how to create the Rings at
this point Galadriel reveals that she's
actually looked into the whole halbrand
thing and that turns out that was a
[ __ ] lie the line of kings in the
south is broken and as we know Aragorn
would come to descend from a lean deal
and a seal door when Hal Bryan said he
took the crest off a dead man he was
being literal and this entire time he's
played every single situation now here
he puts Galadriel in a fantasy with
finrod in which they discusses dagger
you might notice that there's two into
even colors of gold and silver here
which are meant to represent the two
trees of valinor it's a similar scene to
how the opening of the Season played out
and in his fantasy he tries to
manipulate Galadriel into seeing Sauron
wants peace this will of course be under
his Rule and he wanted to touch the
darkness once more he breaks out of this
though and were transported to the boat
Sauron plays it like he's just a nice
guy but Galadriel sees through the
deception and the sweet words similar to
how Galadriel was tempted with the
wandering in Fellowship we get him
trying to tempt her here he says the
line I would make you a queen
stronger than the foundations of the
Earth
which is a call back to this line said
by collateral in Fellowship said a
daughter Lord you would have a queen
is it a call forward I don't know now he
sees rule as saving people and makes you
realize that it's not gonna go down well
with management when she tells them she
saved Sauron I think this is what stops
her from telling people that he's the
dark lord and instead she's like just
don't trade with him again I don't think
she gives a strong enough reason for
this but moving on now similar how she
almost drowned in episode 2 she goes
back into the water but here she's saved
by alrond instead of Hal brand the three
rings are then pitched so that they can
be balanced and using finrod's dagger
they create an alloy for them back with
the half votes we see as they've started
to put plans in place to move on and
learn that the stranger is heading out
to roon similar to how Bilbo broke off
from The Hobbit's ways and went on an
adventure Nori has decided as well that
she wants to go East with him I think
they might potentially end up
introducing more Wizards next season and
we may see the blue ones right against
the brown and even ceremon I thought
these goodbyes were the strongest part
of the episode and we end with a hug
from B who's now put in charge of
leading a caravan I feel like when Nori
comes back she'll find them settled in
the Shire which was known for its safety
it's the opposite side of the map
tomorrow so it's the most likely place
that they go in order to get away from
everything Galadriel sacrifices the
dagger and in doing so she says goodbye
to the last thing that her brother owned
this symbolizes her quest for Revenge
being over and what happens in Mordor
stays in Mordor I guess however elrond
does end up discovering the scroll but
it's too late the elves have now been
saved but they made a deal with the
devil in order to do it the mithril is
dropped into the materials and this
creates what looks like the eye of
Sauron before they're finally made and
if I'm reaching but I also thought this
marking looked like the constellation
but again it might be a reach anyway we
end with the eye of Sauron calling back
to the imagery that we talked about
earlier Sauron has ventured out Immortal
namely Mount Doom to likely Forge the
one ring and take back his land he then
close out to a song and this sings the
words at token wrong out about the
creation of the Ring next season will
likely be Sauron vs zadar and he will
once more take back his land and go even
further to becoming the dark lord and
that wraps up the episode and I thought
it wasn't okay finale that kind of went
through the motions that we expected
obviously we needed the Sauron reveal
the reveal with a stranger and
everything kind of fit into place so
whether you are on board with it to this
point I think's very much going to
decide how much you enjoyed it there are
a lot of things that's going to be
divisive like the stranger being Gandalf
but I've been expecting this for a while
now and kind of saw it coming so I was
kind of used to it I did enjoy the fact
that he had and I am kind of interested
to see where they go with him also the
Sauron reveal was okay there were some
bits that were a bit clunky and
obviously they went through the whole
join me and we can rule this land
together speech that is often given by
villains to the hero so it was okay you
know it delivered on what I thought it
would but I don't think it completely
knocked it out the park
um it was just serviceable of that big
save ads as soon as halbrand walked in
almost acting like a completely
different character I would say yeah I
can see where this is going and not to
Pat myself on the back but a lot of
theory times turned out to be true which
isn't necessarily always a good thing
now as for my thoughts on this series I
think that it's had its ups and downs
and provided an uneven ride overall the
road goes ever on and on and so does the
moaning and though I enjoyed most of the
characters I think that my main faults
with the show were down to its pacing
and structure every time I talk about
this someone inevitably pops up and says
that they like slow stories and don't
mind the pace at all that's totally cool
um and hopefully those people can also
understand why that style isn't for
everyone this is something that
producers themselves have alluded to
with them saying they try to mimic the
long and drawn out World building style
of Jr or Tolkien now I have read and
enjoyed tolkien's books and the poetic
nature of the work I think it works well
in a book where you can just go at your
own pace and stuff but a TV show is a
different format I can falter if you
draw things out too much longer pacing
can work if you're invested in what's
going on but I found the Mysteries were
too clearly Telegraph for me to wonder
about them too deeply in general some
plots were way more intriguing than
others ankle Adriel spent a lot of the
season telling people that Sauron was
coming even after they eventually
listened to her they still had to do
things like episode 5 where they prepped
all the ships and trained instead of
just getting into the meat just give me
the meat and give it to me raw is
basically what I'm saying and because of
that I felt the series got bogged down a
bit too much with some of the slower
moments though the Peter Jackson Trilogy
has its slow moments too we have the
McGuffin of the Ring that's driving the
plot forward and also the paranoia
that's some of our favorite characters
could be corrupted this season didn't
really have that and for a show called
rings of power maybe beyond the last
episode we didn't really get that much
of a focus on them being Creator used I
also think that for newcomers that there
were some things that weren't really
explain enough for people to invest
themselves into morgoth was mentioned
heavily in the intro as being the big
bad and then we switched to Sauron
without any real explanation to the
point that I don't think people who know
who these are will even understand why
morgoth was included even things like
the balrog's birth gets skipped over and
if you don't know about it being on
Earth because the dwarves deep then
you'd have no idea why it randomly
appeared during the fort's motives were
also really weird as it's almost like he
had this prior knowledge that balrogs
could be found so he had to stop the
digging the source material says that
the balrog attacked because the dwarves
are too greedy here though jiren didn't
want to dig too deep for completely
unexplained reasons just little things
like that where I think they could have
bleshed out motivations and explanations
and though things like it didn't ruin
the show for me it did bring the score a
bit lower now as always I want to talk
about what I like too so these reviews
feel a bit more balanced obviously the
visuals and production standard of this
are really high and there was a major
feeling of scope and scale throughout
the entire season bear McCreery did an
excellent job of scoring the series and
they definitely have the materials here
to do big things in season two though
Galadriel is getting a lot of hate
online because say something
controversial I actually like the Arc of
her being vengeful over her brother's
death and then having to find a way to
navigate out this Darkness those she was
a Karen at Point This was meant to be
the point of the character and Hal brand
very much showed her how you get more
bees with honey instead of with vinegar
I think the guy who played at Lindale
was really good and watching him being
forced into putting his son in the line
shows how things are gonna progress in
the direction of their eventual arcs for
me this standouts however or the dwarves
and I think that during Desert and all
this stuff with alrond added a real
heart to the show this cemented the idea
that we can find common ground with
others and help them if the opportunity
arises so I like that stuff I just wish
the focus of the series had more
interesting things in it I talked about
this on a live stream the other day with
Greg John and Ryan and kind of went over
how I think the prologue to episode 1
would have been a brilliant first season
they could have done a Game of Thrones
thing where we got invested in bin Rod
is galadriel's brother only to see a
murder at the end of the season by
Sauron who'd go on to get hyped up as a
big villain Instead This is skipped over
in a five minute scene and it's a missed
opportunity to have our hearts crushed
along with galadriel's so yeah that's my
thoughts on it and I think that was
probably a misfire to release this
alongside House of the Dragon though
totally they're different that has kind
of sucked the window rings of power
sales and it's made it so that the shows
are directly competing with each other
whether you agree they should be
compared or not there are the
comparisons being made it was probably a
wrong move to release them running side
by side so yeah in the end I did enjoy
some parts of rings of power but there
was too much in between these moments
for this to be as good of a season as it
could have been I think it was Dan
Murrell who said reviewing rings of
power was the Kobayashi Maru of TV shows
and that it's a known situation and no
matter what I say someone is gonna get
angry the weeks I've said I've enjoyed
it are being called a shell that's just
saying I liked it because Amazon are
paying me money the weeks I've said I've
not enjoyed it I'm a hater and I even
had a comment saying that I was being
paid by HBO to say rings of power was
bad so yeah you can't win and I'm done
it was fine in the end the real rings of
power was the friends we made along the
way and now at send it over to you to
hear your thoughts on the series we are
in competition right now and giving away
three copies of dollar and thunder on
the 15th of October and all you have to
do to be when the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
you pick the comments at random on the
15th and the winners of the last one are
on screen right now save that to you
then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out one
of our house of the dragon videos which
will be linked on the screen right now
loads of stuff to talk about you're
bloody gonna love it and hopefully I'll
see you over there if I haven't annoyed
every single person who's watched this
video you take care yourself have a good
weekend peace